was genau macht die taliban aus ihrer
nahaufnahme so gefährlich
denn die unberechenbarkeit und die große
brutalität die ihren tag legen und ja
das sich nicht an versprechen gehalten
wird dass sie wirklich mit massiver
gewalt und terror irgendwie menschen vor
ort hinter vorgehen also nicht umsonst
schlichten so viele menschen jetzt aus
angst vor den taliban oder versuchen zu
flüchten aus diesem land
[Musik]
ärgert sie waren lange zeit vor ort man
merkt ihnen immer noch an dass sie das
wirklich trifft sie leiden auch unter
posttraumatischen störungen seitdem
richtig also ich habe seit 2003 seine
posttraumatischen belastungsstörungen
ich war insgesamt sieben mal im einsatz
und ja die erlebnisse vergisst man nie
und jetzt wo die bilder wieder aktuell
sind trifft mich das umso mehr und das
richtig oder das berichtet auch
kameraden wenn diese bilder wenn sie
diese bilder sehen und sie sich
wahnsinnig hilflos fühlen
sie
berichtet dass sich in letzter zeit
immer mehr kameraden bei ihnen melden
die natürlich auch die bilder in den
medien sehen was genau erzählen die
ihnen was sagen die was fühlen die also
die schönen genauso wie ich eine große
trauer und wut und sie fühlen sich
machtlos
viele sagen auch war das jetzt alles
umsonst was ich getan habe ich habe das
auch in verschiedenen medien schon
gesagt wenn ich jetzt auf die 20 jahre
zurückblicke halte ich das ja unser
engagement unsere toten für umsonst für
sinnlos jeder einzelne für sich hat
natürlich dort vor ort erst meine
aufgabe erfüllt und sie war in dem
moment auch sinnvoll wenn ich jetzt auch
die letzten 20 jahre zurückblicke und
die situation vor ort mir anschaue dann
sage ich das war tatsächlich alles
sinnlos weil die menschen erfahren genau
das leid was sie auch vor 20 jahren
erfahren haben
[Musik]